Buenas tardes fue una comparecencia bien
complicada en el parlamento británico en
la cámara de los comunes listas Está
tratando de sobrevivir una semana más en
medio de esta crisis política de la que
es la protagonista y que tiene
peligrando su estadía en el número 10 de
Downey Street listas tuvo que defenderse
prácticamente durante toda la sesión
decir que no va a renunciar que no es de
las personas que se va que no es una
quitter dijo sino que ella va a seguir
dando la pelea esto ante los llamados de
diferentes partidos en la oposición como
los laboristas los liberales demócratas
y los nacionalistas escoceses que
dijeron que ella la protagonista de la
crisis económica que enfrenta el país
por qué todavía está en el cargo Así que
listras dijo que no se va y dijo además
que va a aumentar las pensiones de
acuerdo con la inflación Pero esto por
supuesto lo va a poner muchísima más
presión en otros puntos del gasto fiscal
de las inversiones de los gastos que
hace el país listas también defendió ese
plan económico nuevo que destrozó el que
ella misma presentó hace varias Hace
tres semanas